la place victor hugo de besançon est
fier d'avoir vu naître quatre futurs
grands hommes le littérateur charles
nodier d'abord dans une petite maison
maintenant remplacée par une école
victor hugo bien sûr et puis auguste et
louis lumière les inventeurs du
cinématographe les plaques apposées sur
les façades des maisons natales attire
l'attention des passants évoque aussi à
besançon le souvenir d'autres glorieux
bébé comme charles fourier devenu le
créateur du phalanstère et comme pierre
joseph proudhon qui sera théoricien
socialiste quant à joseph pasteur néo 53
de la rue darren c'était simplement le
père de son fils le père du savant louis
pasteur bien sûr les écrivains ne
manquent pas charles de bernard grand
admirateur de balzac ni rue bersot
l'historien droz les rues pasteur et
tout près tristan bernard
il écrivit qu'ils étaient les grandes
rues comme victor hugo mais qui
s'étaient modestement contenté du numéro
23 tandis que le poète avait vu le jour
au 138 le 140 actuelle
le compte de chardonnay inventeur d'un
procédé de soie artificielle est né dans
l'hôtel petit de marivent à plage encore
né la même année que le futur général
langlois lui au 103 de la rue des
granges et puis place jean gigou fait la
maison natale de jean gigot le peintre
un peu oublié aujourd'hui mais qui avait
constitué une très belle collection de
tableaux et de dessins et qu'il a offert
à la ville de besançon cultivons nos
maisons natales il n'y en aura bientôt
plus du tout car désormais c'est en
maternité que l'on met les enfants au
monde et ce sera peut-être un jour un
argument publicitaire
venez accouché à la clinique machin qui
a vu naître deux prix nobel et trois
académiciens